[Music]
good morning John it's Monday April I
don't care the day after Easter
is what it is it's not actually the day
after Easter it's the day before Easter
and IMing a party in my house which you
may be able to hear in the background
I'm just gonna walk upstairs and see
what happens well that wasn't exactly
what I was expecting but that's what
happened were a lot of people there it
was very fun kind of maybe a little bit
too fun for some people and maybe even a
little bit too fun for me I've heard
that there may be some problems
discussing certain aspects of our lives
and I don't know if I'm okay with that
for example when I drank that entire
bottle of Strawberry Hill flavored
citrus wine I didn't actually drink all
of it there was some discussion about us
as role models and binge drinking Wow
binge drinking I'd really like to try
that sometime because Hank looked like
he was having a blast nerdfighters
Philon tirely sure how much I should
share in these videos which is a little
bit of a problem because you and I are
brothers and we have to communicate and
that includes sharing things like my
massive colossal hangover and the Easter
party that I went to where instead of
candies in the eggs there were condoms
and other forms of contraception and
also edible body gels do you think you
can embarrass me mm-hmm
I can embarrass me worse than you can
embarrass me wait no yes that was a
horrible horrible picture of me limp
wristed and eyeliner and those glasses
really are horrible and as horrible as
that picture was I've decided to embrace
it I sent that picture off to a
laboratory and I had them convert it and
I had them turned me into a baby and a
manga character and the young person in
an old
and a drunk person and a monkey and
through all of it none of them were as
embarrassing as the original but I'm
sure there are even more embarrassing
pictures of me out there
and I know there are more embarrassing
pictures of you out there and I'm gonna
find them I'll see you tomorrow